Julie is with us in New Jersey hi Julie
how are you I'm good Dave how are you
better than I deserve
what's up my husband and I we do not
have any debt Thanks thankful to you and
the Lord and we do have about four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
liquid cash we do want to buy a home in
the next two years or so and we also are
going to have to buy into my husband's
medical practice my question for you is
do we take advantage of the market right
now with some of our liquid cash because
we have very basic retirement but like I
said we have about four hundred and
fifty grand in liquid cash and we just
want to know so what's it going to cost
to buy into the practice and when will
you do that so we would buy into the
practice probably in the next six to
nine months and it'll be about 170 grand
yeah well we don't touch that because we
don't know what's gonna happen in six
months right so for sure 200 sits on the
sidelines okay
for that because that medical practice
is going to buying into that's going to
yield you a lot more than any stock
market return that's going to give you
that's gonna be a better purchase yeah
so that's 200 so now we're dealing with
a quarter of a million in addition to
that that you've got sitting there
potentially for house and this is in
addition to your emergency fund correct
that's correct okay and and then what
you've got to do is you have to decide
from there what you feel like with your
smart mr. Pro or whoever helps you with
your mutual fund selection what you feel
like the market is going to do between
now and the time you're gonna need the
money okay you said three years before
you use it to buy a home as what you
said probably within the next two years
okay two years what do you think the
stock market's gonna do and why in the
next two years I don't know what it's
gonna do obviously no one does I am a
glass-half-full abundant
mentality person and I have a tendency
having survived a several of these
crisises that were supposed to bring
life on the planet to an end and none of
them did but they did bring pain and
they did bring people losing money but
then you know I look up 12 years after
2008 and it's such a distant memory and
some of you never even experienced it
that are young and I looked back to 9 1
1 and I look back to y2k and I look back
to whatever crisis fill in the blank
that caused the stock market to dive and
how quickly did it come back and did he
come back and is the American economy
going to end on the coronavirus answer
no and so I'm not taking a dime out of
the stock market today I've got millions
of dollars invested in mutual funds and
they're all sitting there riding down
and riding up so the question is is it a
great time to buy yeah it's a great time
to buy how much is your stomach going to
be in your throat because of this money
being invested so personally I don't
think I would tell you to put more than
half of it into this and let half of it
sit there so you got 150 to put down on
the house if the stock market became
more 0 which is not going to right but
you got another hundred playing or so
that you know you might make 30 grand on
it you know I might jump up 30 percent
in that two year period of time and so
you might make Nothing on it you might
lose $10,000 but you know you're
probably not gonna lose enough of it
that it keeps you from buying a home
during that two years you know so I
would I would deploy some of it
and if you're you know if you have 0%
you're 0% scared you could deploy all of
it I tell you to do that I could do it
because it wouldn't bother me because
I'm very comfortable with all of that
but but that's different than I just
don't want you why in a way can I say no
I put that money in there and I Uncle
Bill buy a house you know I don't want
you having that conversation with
yourself at one o'clock in the morning
got it to the extent you're going to
don't put any of it in right no yeah I'm
my husband's probably more like you then
and willing to to you know put more in
into the market so okay and would you
just do good you know individuals no I
don't buy any individual stocks way too
much risk I always buy just good growth
stock mutual funds and in the case of
something like that I'm gonna buy a
conservative category like growth and
income maybe a little bit of growth so I
might fit put fifty in a growth and
income and 50 in a growth growth fund
and then the rest of it Park it in the
money market and then you've got the
other 200 sitting there for the for the
practice buy-in and you're gonna be just
fine so Anthony its we tell people tone
it's very very important to get an
intellectual grasp on the risk and face
your own emotions yes sir absolutely and
that's something that I'm doing Dave
I've reached out to my smart Vista pro
last Thursday and just asked them hey
what should I be doing during this time
because I would like to invest a little
bit as well and I and I want to say this
day because I can hear the young people
out there thinking Oh Dave just said I
could possibly make maybe possibly 30%
go up and some money and listen you guys
listen to what he's saying if you have
the money she had four hundred fifty
thousand dollars if you're still in debt
do not look to make an investment do not
do that good I want to say that because
I hear Millennials and young people
thinking oh my goodness I can make this
money no take care of your debt
understand that's $10,000 we're talking
about making three grand there's not
life-changing money there you go Dave do
not go borrowing money on a stupid
credit card to put money in the market
because the market down that's the
opposite end of that you know there's
one of the stupid doing that the other
end of stupid is taking the money out
right now yes because you're freaking
out yes and so it's not the time to be
either steady steady slow and steady
wins the race yes that's that's my thing
I haven't touched nothing I've lost a
lot of money but I mean I done cashed in
I know that's what I'm saying
paper money paper money not reality
there we go I like